good news intubations is down and that's
really good news because the intubations
ultimately lead to the worst news 80%
roughly of people get intubated never
come off the ventilator the number of
new people who are diagnosed with Kovac
about 2,000 still yesterday so when you
see the reduction in rates remember what
we're talking about we're talking about
a reduction in increases you still have
2,000 people every day
about who are walking into a hospital
for the first time or who are being
diagnosed with kovat for the first time
and 2,000 is still a lot of people but
the good news is it means we can control
the virus right we can control the
spread and we did not know for sure that
we could do that we speculated that we
could do it but we didn't know so now we
know that we can control this disease
the bad news is 2,000 people walked into
a hospital yesterday for the first time
with the disease and the worst news is
600 people died yesterday from the
disease that is still continuing at a
really tragic tragic rate of those
deaths 577 in hospitals 29 in nursing
homes we've been watching the nursing
homes because nursing homes in many ways
are ground zero for this situation last
night the number in nursing homes was
relatively low everyone asks the same
two questions when is it over and how do
we get there how do we start to make our
way from here to there when is it over
as I've said you know when is it finally
over it's over when you have a vaccine
and that's 12 months to 18 months we've
said to the FDA any way we can be
helpful in the testing of that vaccine
how do we accelerate that how do
expedited New York is ready willing and
able to do that with the FDA
maybe there's a medical treatment
between now and the vaccine that would
be great but those are unknowns and it's
out of our bailiwick we are working with
a lot of companies that are working on
treatments we're testing treatments in
our hospitals but that's a pure medical
research and development function which
is beyond us at the same time how do we
unpause New York New York is now on
pause how do we unpause it first do no
harm
don't let that infection rate go up to
the best of your ability don't lose the
progress that you have made second now
go back that we have some stability and
we can actually work with the healthcare
system which we had on overdrive for
many many weeks and we had increased the
capacity as you remember every hospital
had to increase capacity 50% I mean just
think about that 50% more beds staffing
those beds during this horrific period
now we have a chance to be more
intelligent frankly about handling our
health care system testing and tracing
testing and tracing testing and tracing
and we need the federal government to
work with us on that and then phasing an
economic return to the quote-unquote new
normal right those are all activities
that are going on at the same time and
that's our plan to quote unquote unpause
New York you stopped everything how do
you now restart that machine in a
coordinated way that doesn't drive up
the infection right that's the balance
that we're trying to strike on unpause
and having businesses open that is a
nuanced question there's no light switch
it's not all businesses go back tomorrow
it's what business is what do they do
what risks do they pose and what changes
can they make in their business to make
them more safe you know this is not just
government deciding it's government
deciding with private businesses who now
have to take a look at this new normal
this new reality and tell us how they
think they can adjust to it one of our
questions and evaluations is how
essential is that business service right
you have to start somewhere right now we
have the economy working with what our
quote unquote essential workers that's
what the grocery stores open that's
where public transit is running all
right so we want to start to bring the
economy back move up one tranche on how
you define essential who whether what's
the next level of essential businesses
are there certain businesses that are
inherently safer or can be safer and
then let's talk about how we reopen them
and where we reopen them and these are
all questions that we have to work
through on a case by case basis but
there is a matrix and the matrix is how
important is the business to society how
essential is service and how risky is
that business from a rate of infection
and obviously the more essential
business the lower the risk the more
they are a priority and then how do you
do it you do it in phases of priority
and then you phase it up the way we
phased it down which is by percentages
and this is going to be an ongoing
process over the coming weeks that we're
working through with the other states
but the what the how the when looking at
how important that business is and what
the risk that business poses and then do
it in coordination with our other states
because this is really
a regional issue and it should be
addressed on that basis coordinating
with the other states doesn't mean we'll
always be in lockstep but we'll talk
through everything first and hopefully
we're not doing something that's
contradictory to another state at a
minimum and so far so good on that
exercise and then analysis is ongoing
but it's not going to be all about what
government does what government does
what the private sector now has to think
about what they do and how they do it
and how they can do it differently in
this new normal reimagine your workplace
and we learned a lot through this
situation people worked from home well
how many people can continue to work
from home and the business still work
how do you socially distance in the
workplace can you socially distance in
your workplace
what are you our new normal procedures
and practices how do you think you're
going to get workers back and forth and
what precautions would you take in the
workplace how would people work and
where were they said or where were they
stand and how do you do it without
conference meetings and how do you do it
without gatherings how are you going to
interact with the public in a way that
keeps the public safe right we're
talking about businesses businesses that
pose a lower risk
tell us how you intend to organize and
conduct your business and can you do it
in a way that poses a lower risk and
what would you do with your workforce to
make sure if an infection happens that
we can jump on it quickly and then as
we're going through all this planning
this is going to be a moment of
transformation for society and we paid a
very high price for it but how do we
learn the lessons so that
this new normal is a better New York and
there are lessons that we must learn
from this because we do need to do
things differently or we can do things
differently and we can do things better
part of the way of course that bridge is
testing it is the single best tool to
inform decisions and to calibrate all of
this this new testing world is a new
frontier for all of us New York State
has been very aggressive about doing
testing we set a very ambitious goal
when we began and I'm happy to say they
did it we've done five hundred thousand
tests in 30 days
that's more than California Florida and
Michigan combined and this is all about
figuring it out first and taking a
system that frankly didn't exist in
creating this testing system in this
testing regimen five hundred thousand
tests in one month that sounds great and
it was great it was a great
accomplishment and congratulations to
everyone who put it together but when
you think of five hundred thousand tests
in one month and then you compare it to
the fact that you have 19 million people
in this state you have nine million
workers the 500,000 doesn't sound so big
right so we have many questions to
answer where do you test how do you get
the supplies how do you coordinate the
private labs how do you coordinate the
demand going to these private labs right
everybody wants testing private sector
companies are calling for testing and
they're going right to the labs everyone
is going right to these labs and 50
states are competing and the federal
government is buying product from these
labs this has to be figured out and it
can only be figured out in partnership
with the federal government on top of
that once you go from testing you have
to trace every person who comes up pause
tres means investigate investigate all
those prior contacts and then one
contact you test that person leads you
to another person so the tracing
investigators are really assembling an
army that does not now exist I spoke to
the White House again this morning about
it I understand that this is a
problematic area and the federal
government is not eager to get involved
in testing I get that but the plain
reality here is we have to do it in
partnership with the federal government
you're talking about supply chains that
go back to China you know we a state
does not have the capacity to do that
and there's no reason why you would have
50 states each trying to figure this out
on their own competing with the federal
government competing with the private
sector so I'm very much looking forward
to the federal government's willingness
to tackle this understanding that it
will be imperfect at best but if we work
together we can do better than any of us
could do alone and that's what this is
all about you're not going to achieve
optimum performance
you can't put together this national
system with perfection
so people are understandably reluctant
to get involved but understanding the
the risk and understanding that it's
never going to be done perfectly if we
work together we can do better and
that's what we have to actually
accomplish we have to strengthen the
health healthcare system our surge in
flux which is the first time we've ever
called upon all these hospitals to work
together and coordinate every hospital
was basically its own enterprise and
then we go back and say well you all
have to work together and coordinate and
we're going to help you coordinate it
was first time that's ever happened we
understand about a stockpile like
we've never understood before we
understand about sharing resources like
we've never understood before and we
understand about sharing among states
and how good people were in New York
when we needed it and States stepping up
and sending us ventilators and I said
New Yorkers don't forget and New Yorkers
are the most generous and most gracious
and will be there when people need help
New Jersey is still looking at their
curve rising the wave hasn't crested in
New Jersey they're our neighbors
anything we can do to help
I've told governor Murphy all yesterday
there was a square here and we're going
to send 100 ventilators to New Jersey
but the key to all of this the
calibration is the infection rate and
this gets a little technical but I need
people to really understand this why
don't you open tomorrow because we're
afraid the infection rate will go up and
everything we've been doing is too slow
the infection rate well how do you track
the infection rate we don't we don't
track infection rates we see
hospitalization rates which are
different a hospitalization rate is a
person who got infected and became
seriously ill so they had to go to the
hospital but we don't know how many
people have been infected or are getting
infected
we only know at this point how many
people walk into a hospital okay or how
many people get tested in a nursing home
if you have advanced testing then you'll
have a better idea what percent of your
population has actually been exposed
that's what the antibody testing is all
about but the key is as you're making
this calibration on the reopening of the
economy as you bring you more people out
of their homes how fast is that virus
spreading and how quickly is that
infection rate rising
right doctor foul she said early on that
this virus spreads it doesn't very well
and we know that and we've learned it
the hard way the rate of infection is
everything okay all those early
projection models assumed a higher rate
of infection a higher rate of spread
that's why they were calling for so many
more hospital beds
how many more mortalities because they
projected a higher rate of spread that
has not happened so far
caveat so far we've controlled the beast
we brought the rate of spread down if
their rate of spread actually happened
we would have been in a much much worse
situation and we would have been in a
really bad place I mean their
projections were staggering and it
didn't happen because we slowed the
models but remember what they were
talking about CDC which is supposed to
be the preeminent source 160 million to
214 million people infected they were
projecting that was only March 13th
that's what the CDC was projecting you
know how many 162 214 million are we
only have 328 million people in the
country they were projecting more of
half more than half of the population
and maybe two-thirds of the population
infected and that was only a month ago
they were saying 2.4 million people 221
million people would be hospitalized
do you know how many that is we only
have 900,000 hospital beds in the nation
they were saying by their projection a
minimum of twice as many people would
need hospital beds as we have Hospice
let's just imagine that that was the CDC
the White House coronavirus has forced
the same thing White House Quran of a
virus task force was saying one point
five to two point two million deaths
deaths and that was the White House
coronavirus task force as of March 31
okay worse best-case scenario one
hundred to two hundred forty thousand
with mitigation efforts March 31 just
over two weeks ago
so and that's why all of these models
said the same thing they were all
believing a higher infection rate now
and that's McKinsey and that's Columbia
and that's Cornell that's all of them
that's the Gates funded model they were
all projecting a higher infection rate
we slowed the infection rate by our
actions and that's why we're in a better
position today now what does the
infection rate mean and I know this gets
a little granular but people have to
understand that if they're going to
understand why we need to do what we
need to do the infection rate is how
many people does one person infect okay
how fast is the virus spreading from one
person to another and they talk about
the R nought factor the R nought factor
is the projected spread of the virus
okay if one person infects less than one
other person the disease is on the
decline if one person basically infects
one more person the rate of spread is
stable I get infected
i infect one one person infects one when
you have a really situation out of
control is one first person in fact
two people or more because then the
increase is just exponential and that's
fire through dry grass this is what they
were all trying to project and this is
what we have to control as we start to
reopen the economy we say we turn the
valve on the economy we open a little
bit and we watch the meter right what's
the meter the meter is the
hospitalization rate or even better the
virus spread rate so you start to turn
that Valve to start to bring people out
of their homes you start to reopen
businesses you see that number going up
turn the valve back right away
and this is what we're trying to deal
with going forward and again nobody has
been here before so we're trying to
figure it out if one person if the virus
spread increases to the place where one
person affects two people that is an
outbreak if one person is only infecting
one other person that is basically a
stable increase ideally one person is
infecting less than one person and that
is a decline of the spread of the virus
and that's what we're shooting for
just to belabor this one more point
where you've seen an outbreak epidemic
spread it's when one person is infecting
more than one other person that's when
you're out of control on the Diamond
Princess cruise the infection rate was
one person in facts to point to
additional people
Wuhan was one person was infecting two
people or three people the 1918 pandemic
one person was infecting one and a half
to two point eight on our severe
projection one person was infecting one
point four to one point eight on the
moderate projection one person was
infecting 1.2 to 1.4 okay what we've
done
because of our mitigation effort social
distancing stay home lock the door we
brought it to less than one hour
infection spread rate is point nine okay
Luhan which really closed down
everything everything everything and and
locked it up
Wuhan brought the infection rate down to
0.3 okay so that's the range we're
talking about but when you think about
that we're now 0.9 we only have a margin
of error of 0.9 to 1.2 1.2 takes you
back to the high projection rate we're
at 0.9 that does not leave you a lot of
wiggle room so you're gonna start to
phase the reopening you're at 0.9 now
after this entire closed down if you go
to 1.2 you're gonna have a problem again
so you see how narrow the window is but
new york pause has worked the closed
down has worked that's how we controlled
the beast that's how we got it down to
0.9 however we're not there yet we're
just at 0.9 again Wuhan got down to 0.3
so we have to continue doing what we're
doing
I'd like to see that infection rate get
down even more the New York pause
policies the closed-down policies will
be extended in coordination with other
states to May 15th I don't want to
project beyond that period that's about
one month one month is a long time
people need certainty and clarity so
they can plan I need a coordinated
action plan with the other states so one
month we'll continue to close down
policies what happens after then I don't
know we will see depending on what the
data shows what does that mean tell me
what
our infection rate spread is is a point
9 is it 1 is a point 7 tell me what the
hospitalization rate is and then the
experts will tell us the best course of
conduct based on that data no political
decisions no emotional decisions data
and science we're talking about human
lives here as as relatively simple and
possibly annoying as it seems wearing a
mask is one of the best things that we
can do and I understand I'm getting a
lot of not happy phone calls off what I
said yesterday about wearing a mask in
public but I'm sorry miss people unhappy
I do not consider it a major burden and
it really is a simple measure that can
save lives and yes people say it's a
personal intrusion on them but again
remember it's not just about you right I
have rights also and my kids have rights
and your kids have rights and you have a
right for another person to take
reasonable safeguards not to get
infected so the masks work we said in
public today I'm going to include public
transportation systems private
transportation carriers for hire
vehicles any operator of a public system
an operator of a private carrier and for
hire vehicles must wear a mask at all
times what does this mean if you get on
the bus you need to wear a mask if you
get in a train you need to wear a mask
if you get into a private car service
uber lyft the operator needs to wear a
mask if you get on a private bus the
operator needs to wear a mask and you
need
to wear a mask on a on a private carrier
so is this inconvenient yes but you're
in a closed environment by definition
you're not socially distancing by
definition you're the front seat of a
car to a backseat of a car
you're once eating a bus to another seat
in the bus this is a precaution for
everyone that I think balances
individual liberties with a social
conscience this will going to affect
Friday a p.m. ultimately what determines
the rate of infection you do and I do
that's what this all comes down to as
simple as it sounds
it's not about government it's not about
anything else it's about what people
decide to do and what people have
decided to do they have brought this
infection rate down it's that simple
nurses doctors did a phenomenal job
first responders the phenomenal job
essential workers did a phenomenal job
but that rate came down because people
change their behavior that's what
happened it is about the behavior of our
people it's that simple
it's our behavior it's our level of
discipline it's how we educate our
children
it's how considerate we are of others
what we're what we're doing will induce
a fraud others health in our community
that's what makes all the difference on
what we're doing and it is the simple
things it's wearing a mask it's washing
your hands it's the hand sanitizer it's
the social distance it's making sure
your children understand what to do what
not to do
it's all of these simple procedures that
seem almost insignificant but on a
collective basis make all the difference
in the world and it is making smart
choices
I want to get out of the house
I'm going crazy I need to do this I need
to do this I know but be smart be smart
and engage what you're doing relative to
everyone else and relative to the
overall goal but I will tell you and I
don't know that people truly appreciated
this I don't know that I did of all the
unique aspects that we have learned
going through this the most positive and
the most surprising to me has been how
people have responded the policies that
I have communicated are not worth the
paper they are printed on I could stand
up here as governor and say we must do
this we must do this we must do this
these are some of the most life changing
policies government has ever issued
think about it this is not government
saying here's your tax rate here's a age
of voting this is government saying stay
in your house don't touch another person
wear a mask government I don't even have
the ability to enforce these measures on
any scale if people said I'm not willing
to do it
so these policies which are difficult
which are life-changing they are being
implemented by people because people are
choosing to do the right thing it is
that simple and what this is all about
today the masks on on transportation I
trust in New Yorkers you know I believe
if the facts are presented to the people
in this state New Yorkers will do the
right thing what is the right thing
there's always the right thing it is the
appropriate path that is socially and
more
correct and New Yorkers have a very
strong right thing quotient they know
what the right thing is when they hear
it and all I'm trying to do is give them
the facts and the information to explain
why I'm suggesting these actions they
decide whether or not to follow them I
can't put a mask on 17 million people 17
million people would decide whether or
not they'll do it but they have done it
because they have the facts they have
the information they understand the
risks they understand the rewards they
understand the consequences and what
they have done has worked and it's
brought this state forward and it'll
bring this nation forward and that's
that's New Yorkers at their best and
that's because we are New York tough and
because New York tough is more complex
than the word suggest it's smart it's
United it's disciplined and it's loving
and New York New Yorkers have proven
that time and time again every day for
46 days I will let all talk over
everyone I will I'll make sure we answer
I'll get to you to answer the question
and let's just start are you first don't
you in Cornell New York at least ten
nursing home residents have died of
koban nineteen Philmont there have been
at least 23 cases and six steps that one
nursing home the state helped match has
15 residents at a New Windsor assisted
living facility how many in which
nursing homes have reported clusters
outbreaks or requested mass testing from
the state and where are they and is the
state advising nursing home is facing
outbreaks to open Cove it only units or
transfer patients elsewhere I will get
you I don't know ever we have hundreds
and hundreds of nursing homes in this
state so I don't know what has happened
in every nursing home in the state I'm
known
first-hand knowledge of what happened
with the nursing homes in Hornell New
York but we will get you today a list of
information by nursing home to the best
we have and as we get that updated we'll
get it to you Jesse mayor de Blasio is
talking about a seven point four billion
dollar hit in terms of tax revenue have
you discussed help for the city of New
York visa vie that as well as you know
the 1.2 million people who are known
yeah Jesse it's simple yes we've had
multiple conversations it's not just New
York City it's Nassau County Suffolk
County was just the county it's every
county in the state it's every local
government in the state and the short
answer is we cannot do it you know I
have a 10 to 15 billion dollar hole so I
mean not I'm not in any position to help
any of them that's why I've said this is
where the federal government has to step
in and it defies understanding that the
federal government is going to say we
passed major pieces of legislation Pat
us on the back to protect the economy
and move the economy forward but you
don't fund state and local governments
and when you don't fund the state and
local government it means the state
local government has to turn around and
cut everybody that relies on them it's
not smart it's not right it's
counterproductive I understand you don't
get the same political credit when you
fund New York State in New York City or
Nassau County or Suffolk County because
it doesn't represent any voters any
people it's just a governmental entity I
get that and I get that politically they
like to pass legislation where they can
call up someone when they get home and
say hey Jesse I got a check for you I
understand that but at one point you
have to put the politics aside and say
we have to do something that's actually
makes a difference and how do you can
you even pretend
and that you're addressing this crisis
when you are starving state and local
governments and that's not a Democrat to
Republicans National Governors Governors
Association headed by a chairman whose
Republican governor Hogan great guy
great governor myself as vice chairman
we sent the letter saying that to the
administration and by the way I say it
to my Democratic congressional members I
said to Senator Schumer I said to
Senator Gillibrand you pass a piece of
legislation that starves state and local
governments you're not helping the
country you're just not well we have to
get to yes it doesn't matter to get to
yes if the bill doesn't do with the
purposes to get specific information
about we are putting it we're putting it
together you know you have you know you
appreciate the practical reality here
that's why I say watch this whole
reporting system you have hospitals that
are dealing with hell every day and
you're basically saying make sure your
report isn't late which is what the
Department of Health says nursing homes
that are dealing with hellacious
situations well make sure your report is
on time yeah and look I've been on the
phone with these types of facilities and
they say I understand make sure my
report is on time I have seven people
critically ill I'm short-staffed I don't
have enough PPE and you're giving me a
hard time about reports so in the
balance of things I understand the
degree of difficulty but and how many
nursing homes are 613 nursing homes
right so you're not talking about one
phone call but you are getting the data
it is coming in when will we have is do
we know that
cases since testing started are you
concerned about seeing that number two
checkup and why might that be well the
hospitalization testing testing is not
indicative of anything in my opinion it
is not a random sample it is a function
of how many tests you were doing what's
been happening is our testing capacity
is going up as our testing capacity goes
up the more tests you do the more
positives you find remember the testing
is not random it's people who believe
they are positive because of the
circumstances they were exposed to a
positive person etc so you're getting
people who you think are positive to
test and then the more tests you take
the more positives you're going to find
the hospitalization rate of any of these
rates the most indicative is the
hospitalization rate because what it's
telling you is these are people who are
infected and were seriously ill that's
what the hospitalization rate tells you
it's the only real data you now have it
doesn't tell you the rate of infection
spread and whether it's increasing or
decreasing but it tells you how many
people walked into the hospital who were
positive after they were tested and who
was seriously ill that's the only number
you have that is statistically
representative numbers and because they
change the way that they're recording so
now they're saying they added something
like 3,800 new deaths based on in home
deaths what do you say to that do you
think that the president is correct
saying that and also one is the state
going to start having that separate
category yeah Melissa knows this better
than I do look I think what you're
seeing is well first I don't know what
the president said specifically what his
words were and I don't why wouldn't he
York City want to inflate a death toll I
mean that doesn't make a lot of sense
it's bad enough as it is it's painful
enough as it is why would you want to
inflate a Death Zone look I don't know
but even more bizarre than usual that
anyone would want to do that I think
what's happening is they're changing CDC
put out different guidelines about what
numbers you must report we've always
said all we really know our deaths in a
hospital or deaths in a nursing home
could people be dying at home because of
the corona virus and we're not counting
them yes
was this a rough estimate yes so now
we're trying to refine the estimate
other categories of other possibilities
I think that's what it is more than
anything it's more of a reporting
process but Melissa do you know anything
well it's exactly what the governor said
so the CDC put out guidance on reporting
so actually the president's own CDC that
put out this guidance and what and the
city was very clear they actually did
not tack on that number to the total
death count they created a new category
that's called probable deaths this gets
murky right because a lot of people are
dying of various things and if it's
shortness of breath or you had a fever
there's a lot of assumptions that could
be going on behind the positive
everybody knows in this room Assemblyman
Brodsky the assumption was that he had
died from kovat a few days later they
discovered it actually wasn't cope it so
the number is not precise and the city
actually did not put that number into
the death count number it's a separate
category I actually believe the press
miss reported this in some instances and
conflated the two and so that's what it
was but they they did not pad the
numbers and this was a CDC directed
category that the city started reporting
that the state is actually also working
to report
did you want to add something dark it's
exactly what you mentioned it's the
presume is most that their presumed
deaths if somebody died from something
which may have been a different
respiratory illness and they said well
maybe it's a virus the Post reported
last week that EMS and law enforcement
were going to homes and getting though
that raw data and saying hey this could
potentially be a much larger number so
is that the kind of misreporting no no
so but I'm saying when I say conflating
I'm saying there's probable deaths and
then there's the people who we know to
have confirmed died of COBIT they tested
positive or after they died there was
not hopsie done they tested them and
they confirmed after they died that they
had covin so probable is a category that
it's somebody who died and based on the
symptoms or based on how they died they
believed that it could probably have
been kovat so that's that category the
underreporting of the deaths in the home
is another added complication into all
of this but to answer your first
question the city did not pad the
numbers they created a separate category
to address the probable deaths which was
a directive of the CDC yeah I think what
happened yeah I think I think that
refresh is my recollection I don't think
the city put the numbers together
I think The Times wrote a story that put
the numbers together and then said they
had a much higher number I get it's a
great headline but it's not totally
accurate Karen
I have shortage of dialysis machines we
have heard that we are looking into this
about those who need renal dialysis and
to make sure the machines are available
for individuals and and regarding having
kidney failure as a result of of having
a coronavirus often when people get that
ill and end up in the intensive care
unit with multi-organ system failure
multiple problems the kidneys are one of
the organs which take the hardest-hit
initially we have heard about an
individual report but there aren't
shortages that that that are across the
board now there's everyone's well we've
heard that they need a dialysis machine
and we worked on that to get them if
they have a shortage Karen they call us
we have these daily inventory equipment
sharing as a surge flex so if any
Hospital has a shortage of anything on a
daily basis they let us know and then we
find that and we've been able to find
that equipment for them or that PPE so
nobody's had an actual shortfall but if
somebody had a problem that they
couldn't do dialysis because they didn't
have machines they would have more than
likely let the state know two years
yesterday when referring to the mass
mandate you said it's not that
inconvenient you said what's the big
deal for many people we've learned it is
a big deal to wear a mask they feel that
this is a symbol of government control a
lot of people feel that this is a simple
people are falling prey to fear and
we've seen doctors on the news for weeks
now saying that regular Maddox regular
medical masks and the cloth masks do
little to protect you from coronavirus
do you feel like you're under playing
the impacts of your mandate no I said I
don't know how can be on the plane I
said that I know there's a lot of
opposition to this I've had many people
say they don't like it so no I'm fully
aware of the opposition to wearing a
mask it's a face covering right just
we're all saying the same thing it's a
mask or a cloth covering of the nose and
mouth it doesn't have to be a mask it
could also be a cloth covering but no I
understand that people do not like it
and people understand some people do not
like it and some people think it is an
imposition and it is a government
overreach unfinished by the way some
people think the closed down order was a
government overreach some people think
that this is all a fabrication and a
political conspiracy to them I say if
you don't think 600 people died
yesterday and if you don't think that's
a problem I disagree with you if you
doubt that 600 people died I'll bring
you to see the 600 people so is it a
fabrication no 600 people died yesterday
okay and that's a reality we deal with
every day we want to see fewer people
die I'm asking New Yorkers to wear a
mask not just to protect yourself but to
protect other people from you if you
have the virus
you can infect infect other people and
you have a liability a responsibility
not
affect me because you're sick and that's
what a mask would help I understand the
opposition my phone's ringing off the
hook with the opposition I also
understand what 600 deaths mean I
understand the toll on the health care
system I understand the nurses and the
doctors who are stretched to their
limits I understand the police officers
who go out there every day and who are
afraid and asking New Yorkers to wear a
mask at this time I think is more than
reasonable I understand that people
disagree you know it depends on how good
we are at reducing the spread of the
virus and we don't know that it also
depends on when they come up with a
medical treatment and we don't know that
so I understand people want certainty in
closure but we don't have it we don't
have let's do some more question
well look we financially if we don't get
the federal government to actually pass
a piece of responsible legislation and
I've said to my to the extent they care
for my two cents our senators don't pass
a piece of legislation if it's not
responsible well then they'll say we
didn't pass legislation yes I wouldn't
sign a piece of I wouldn't pass an
irresponsible piece of legislation
better than passing an irresponsible
piece of legislation right if those are
the options life is options so yeah we
are at a point financially where we have
a 10 to 15 billion dollar deficit
yesterday I was
about well why not just let the raises
go through for state workers when you
are broke it would be irresponsible to
do these things
I do hope and believe the federal
government should have a more inclusive
policy right let's do more well we're
looking at it but we have real financial
problems right now you know as I said
there's not going to be a hundred
percent conformity of the plans more
it's understanding what they're doing
what we're doing so we don't conflict
and bump into each other with which has
happened in the past because people make
decisions the state parks look I can
argue it either way right all of these
things are judgment calls but I don't
think that's an especially problematic
you particularly people who are
self-employed who have lengthy
documentation so again let's do some
context here as Jesse noted in the Labor
Department's gonna be putting out the
figures later today another 400,000
people filed claims rent insurance in
the last week the week ending this past
Friday which brings us up to 1.2 million
claims in the last five weeks to give
you guys a sense of comparison during
the entirety of the 2008 crash New York
State lost 300,000 jobs so in terms of
the volume that Department of Labor is
dealing with just for everyone's
understanding at this point they have
done completed nine hundred twenty-five
thousand claims there's two hundred and
seventy-five thousand claims that are
outstanding some of those people are
from the last week some of those people
unfortunately date back to the middle of
March most of the people who date back
to the middle of March are people who
require additional forms for as you said
people who are self-employed people who
are contractor
so that process has been taking longer
we're working together to try to figure
out the best way possible to expedite
this it's great that the system has
worked better for some if you're one of
the people who are still struggling it
doesn't matter at all and we understand
that and I sympathize with that and I
apologize for that and we're gonna
continue to do everything we can to
bring the system up to deal with the
scale as soon as possible that's here
let's do one more so yes we're working
on that and we're working with local
governments in making sure people who
can't pay for a mask can have one
remember it's not a mask it's a face
covering so it can be a handkerchief
abandon that can be a cloth covering etc
can be stylish or fashionable or just
boring and plain like mine I'm gonna go
to work
thank you for asking his wife now tested
positive so he feels obviously you know
we're not sure how Christina is my
brother's wife how she how she got the
virus but assuming he gave it to her
cause she was helping take care of him
he feels bad about that on a personal
level and on a practical level he's sick
in the basement she's the worst